moi je dis priorité aux jeunes quand
j'ai entendu macron dire nous la
priorité au mode au début du confinement
marchandises est la priorité des
priorités c'est de protéger les plus
vulnérables
oui c'est vrai en temps de crise
sanitaire aiguë autrement dit en mars ou
en avril quand il y avait des centaines
de morts ou des 1000 morts chaque jour
maintenant il faut apprendre comme dit à
nouveau mercredi maintenant macron à
juste titre il faut apprendre à vivre
avec le virus
on ne va pas faire pendant 20 ou 30 ans
notre prière absolue de protéger les
plus vieux d'entre nous a une fois je
peux le dire parce que j'en fais deux
parties mois avec mai 68 ans en tant que
père de famille en tant que futur grand
père j'ai envie de dire sur le long
terme la priorité des priorités c'est
les jeunes en général et les enfants en
particulier
reste que j'appelle le sanitairement
correct comme le politiquement correct
il ya des choses qu'on n'a pas le droit
de dire avec lesquels au fond tout mode
jacob quand je dis qu'il est plus triste
de mourir à 30 ans qu'à 68 ans personne
ne dit le contraire oui mais c'est
choquant de le dire idée mais je crois
que ce sanitairement correct est
dangereux parce qu'il risque de nous
mener justement un ordre sanitaire qui
est beaucoup plus grave parce que le
politiquement correct c'est des choses
qu'on n'a pas le droit de dire l'ordre
sanitaire c'est des choses qu'on n'a pas
le droit de faire attention parce que là
le passage de l'un à l'autre peut
devenir insidieux et peut-être un jour
irréversible et donc vous avez raison je
m'étonne d'être si seuls dans ce combat
là que je ne mène pas par intérêt
personnel mais que je mène je dirais par
conviction de père de famille et pour
moi c'est extrême importance vient de
faire un texte pour un livre collectif
écrit surtout par des médecins se
maladies infectieuses et je les appelais
brève réflexion d'un philosophe père de
famille parce que ma position en
l'occurrence sur le mobile elle est
déterminée d'abord par le fait que j'ai
trois enfants qui sont de jeunes adultes
des trentenaires et je ne veux surtout
pas qu'il sacrifie en fois que ce soit
leur vie leur bonheur le lille en
liberté alors à la santé de leurs vieux
papa
[Musique]